james in salem
virginia hi jim welcome to the dave
ramsey show
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call here's my question i'm working with
a
young man who recently got out of jail
he's a felon with an rso
um he's deeply in debt he's got about
500 plus
dollars a month in in debt and he's only
earning
about 2 000 a month you know nobody
wants to really hire him
um i've offered to pay for
financial peace university for him if he
would do it
but he keeps blocking he he just doesn't
want to
he doesn't want to be financial
financially
sound or make some good financial
decisions
because he wasn't trained that way his
his dad died when he was
very young his mother was a drunk he
just
he's never been trained so my question
is what questions do i need to ask him
that help him kind of see the light and
understand the way that he's going is
isn't the best
without just walking away because right
now he
is as you say um
or um worshiping at the idol of the fico
score
oh man uh jim let me ask you this
question how did you come across this
young man what's your relationship with
him
i have no relationship with him other
than a friend of mine
was visiting him in jail and so now the
two of us
are you know trying to help him a little
bit on the outside but we have not given
him any money
we're only kind of spending some time
with him and
advising him on some things okay yeah
all right
what is he um other than the money piece
what are you all talking about
um you know i take him out on a farm and
work with him
um i mean we're building a fence for uh
for an elderly gentleman i mean we kind
of talk about
lots of different things we go out to
dinner um
you know but he knows he knows your
purpose
in his life is to better his life right
to
to mentor him disciple him into being a
better guy right
well i hope so i mean why does he think
you're hanging around
right well yeah i've asked myself that
very same question and
he doesn't have any friends he's only
got just a couple
you know nobody wants to associate with
him even the churches you know won't
take him in because of his rso
classification so um you know i'm sorry
i'm stupid what's rsl
all right so no rso yeah it's uh
registered
sex offender right oh okay yeah okay
thanks
um you know and and i can understand you
know
why everybody is cautious but uh he's
just
it's just a tough situation yeah but
when it comes to money
he's not making good decisions and i and
i'm trying to help him
understand that he doesn't earn very
much money
jim here's the thing go ahead um he
can't make right decisions
right now because he doesn't know any
better so
i think i like what dave was talking
about what are you talking with him
outside of money because before we can
address the money we got to address the
mindset
and to address the mindset you got to
think about it he has to
see different things and experience
different things
to register in a mind to shift how he
thinks and looks and process things
around money
and so this was going to be kind of hard
because he is rso
but i think with yourself and with other
people that we can get around him in a
community way in a safe
and in a wise way we have to start
exposing him to
other things that will start shifting
his mind so not just with money but just
in life in general
you know he's made some poor decisions
in the past clearly
so how do we start addressing his mind
to start
thinking differently to where we can see
him change from the inside
out then once we start seeing his mind
shift the way he looks and process
life then we'll see and be able to
address the money issues
but i really wouldn't stress about how
do i help him right now with the money
there's something much bigger than money
what i'm thinking about is my
my buddy who's uh wealthy today who grew
up in the hood
by his own words and he said getting out
of the hood was easier than getting the
hood out of me
exactly and so um i guess i'm just
asking the guy a lot of questions
where do you want to go where do you
want to be in five years
i i'm the guy the reason i'm hanging out
with you is i want you to be in a better
place
later than you are today i want you to
have more money than you do today
i want you to have a better life and a
better reputation than you do today
i want you to have a better job and a
better career than you do today
uh i want you to you know experience a
a transformational healing of your life
and i want to be there while it happens
i want a front row seat to this
happening
and i want to i want to welcome my arm
around your shoulder and my
my my foot kicking your butt to cause
this to happen
now how can i do that what what can we
do because i i really
i you know i could build fences with you
for the next 15 years
and you don't change and that's not
that's not going to work for me
i'm building fences with you literal
fences
so that we so i can build a connection
to you so you can get better
now how can i help you do that i am not
interested
in you being in the same place five
years from now if that's all you want
for your life
i can't help you get there that's not
gonna be okay with me
and some stuff like that and just go
just get him dream i think i see stuff
in you i see that you can be
somebody but you're gonna have to decide
that you're gonna take some steps to be
there
and i can show you the steps then i'm
standing here ready man
and um so the thing that was those kinds
of things and stories like the
andrew carnegie's carnegie story if
you're from pittsburgh it's carnegie
but uh the the very very wealthy family
and their uh you know their foundation
formed basically the public library
system in america
and the reason is is that andrew
carnegie
uh didn't have squat and
his officer in the union army opened up
his own
personal home library to him and
encouraged him
to go be somebody and to read and that
reading in that library changed his life
and so that now consequently there's
libraries all over america
three generations later because of that
man
that union officer in the union army
after the civil war opening his home
his home library because there were no
public libraries
uh and encouraging the young man to read
and that's who you are you're that union
officer
in this story and so i i just would put
it out there that
you know i can take you some places man
but you got to be willing to get in the
car
yeah yeah and have patience during that
time as well yeah i mean you have
patience with him but
this idea that i'm going to sit on the
side of the road and suck my thumb
because listen there's a whole lot of
stuff that everybody has in their past
yes
and that's a horrible label to have on
you it's a horrible label to have on you
but it doesn't mean you can't do
anything you can run your own business
and do anything you want to do as long
as you don't violate parole and laws
on registration and so forth but you can
run your own business
and do whatever i mean nobody comes into
a sub shop and asks
if if you're making subs if you own the
sub shop if you're an rso or not
they just want to know as a sandwich
good you know
and that's the whole thing so he can
redeem his life he has
he's not he's not ruined for life